im ersten moment gedacht ja der strom
wieder da sein
keiner war sich dieser situation die
darauf kam bewusst und das ausmaß war ja
quasi erst am nächsten morgen spürbar
also eigentlich waren wir nicht
vorbereitet das muss man mal ganz klar
so sehen fünf minuten zehn minuten eine
viertelstunde halbe stunde der strom war
weg und blieb weg
[Musik]
woran ich mich genau erinnere ist dass
es unendlich schneite der schnee nicht
aufhörte rund ums haus den schnee schon
weg schaufelte aber immer neuer kamen
die ersten lampen finger zu flackern so
man merkte so der strom ist nicht mehr
ganz so da wie ihr mann ihn geworfen und
dann bezahlt so wie wir damals auch die
idee gekommen um sein neues buch schon
mal geraten was für den dem jahr gekauft
hatten
in einsatz zu bringen und dann war ich
meine so gegen fünf kurz nach 5 da
fehlen mir dabei den strom dann komplett
weg da was dann wirklich dunkel und
nachdem der strom halten immer noch
nicht wieder da wo ich gesagt okay das
ist ein gutes zeichen gehen nach hause
macht feierabend ein schönes wochenende
[Musik]
auf der autobahn standen in einem 45
kilometer stau schon mehrere hundert
fahrzeuge dort war eine stromleitung ein
hochspannungsmast umgeknickt die kabel
waren quasi vom schnee so schwer
geworden dass sie quasi strand also was
ich weiß nicht auf 10 15 meter über der
fahrbahn und feuerwehr hatte abgespielt
oder gegen königs zurück und nix mehr
vor
und die sind dann quasi auf der autobahn
damals gekappt worden dass die
ereignisse an diesem wochenende dermaßen
dramatik annehmen würden hätte ich nie
gedacht
ein strom blackout wie im münsterland
ist deutschland ausreichend darauf
vorbereitet
ein bundestags bericht aus dem jahr 2011
stellt fest
nein in dem papier vom büro für
technikfolgenabschätzung heißt es ein
kollaps der gesamten gesellschaft wäre
kaum zu verhindern also die kernaussage
war auch für mich überraschend wie
scharf das problem ist wenn einige tage
lang flächendeckend der strom ausfällt
haben wir schlimmste katastrophen
ereignisse weil immens viele strukturen
einfach nicht mehr funktionieren
[Musik]
wir haben gewartet gehofft dass der
strom halt vielleicht dann nach einer
stunde nach zwei stunden zurückkommt ist
tat sich aber nichts der strom war weg
und blieb weg es war relativ schnell
klar dass die ursache dafür daran lag
dass der schnee so schwer gewesen ist
und auf den elektroleitungen angefroren
ist dass einige strommasten gebrochen
sind und dann ist das wie eine
kettenreaktion der einen nach dem
anderen fiel um 1 waren über 80
strommasten im münsterland damals
umgekippt sind
das kann man sich nicht vorstellen dass
daraus wie eingeknickt wie die
streichhölzer dass das tatsächlich
wirklich stahlkolosse waren
konnte man sich in dem moment einfach
nicht vorstellen
als feuerwehrmann sieht man das oder
sind wir es gewohnt ich sag mal gewissen
schema dazu arbeiten aber als mensch
muss ich sagen hat mich das sehr
beunruhigt es war nicht abzuschätzen wie
wir diese situation unter kontrolle
bekommen würden hans-josef fell war
langjähriger bundestagsabgeordneter der
grünen und beschäftigt sich seit jahren
mit energieerzeugung und sicherheit
doch was wenn die wegfällt fell ist
mitinitiator des bundestags bericht aus
dem jahr 2011 was hat sich zur
verbesserung seitdem getan
relativ wenig wir sehen ja dass wir
weiterhin eine sehr zentrale
stromversorgung haben und jedes zentrale
element ist ja sehr anfällig wenn die
katastrophen richtig zuschlagen
die steiermark in österreich in der
gemeinde lastigen schlägt die
katastrophe zu 1998 ereignet sich hier
ein folgenschweres grubenunglück die
gesamte rettungsmannschaft stirbt häuser
stürzen ein
dann fällt der strom aus 10 gedenktafeln
erinnern an die verstorbenen die
katastrophen der vergangenheit prägen
die gemeinde bis heute für einen neuen
stromausfall will man gewappnet sein
der erste anlass war ihm vor 22 jahren
das grubenunglück in lassing
wirtschaftsmesse komplett einmal ohne
strom gewesen
um zehn uhr abends wenn man komplette
stille alles finster
man hört auch direkt angst bekommen und
auch die stürme 2003 und 2006 im winter
die wollen eigentlich für uns dann sehr
ausschlag geben
dadurch stromnetz eigentlich durch
umgeworfene bäume und sonstige
überlastung in zusammengebrochen ist die
la singer setzen deshalb auf eine
unabhängige dezentrale stromversorgung
experten sprechen von sogenannten
insellösungen das herzstück des systems
das schulzentrum mit einer speziellen
photovoltaikanlage die ist blackout
resistent das besondere bei der black
hat resistenten photovoltaik anlage ist
sollte notfall des notfalls wenn immer
ein stromausfall beim stromnetz ist die
sonne zu wenig strom liefern dann kann
mit einem stromgenerator der energie
speicher geladen werden das dauert circa
zwei bis drei stunden dann sind die
stromspeicher wieder geladen und es ist
gibt weiterhin strom und der
stromgenerator muss nicht 24 stunden
laufen
so können sie in lassing treibstoff
sparen denn auch daran mangelt es bei
einem blackout
durch die dezentrale stromversorgung mit
photovoltaikanlage generator und
batterie hat die gemeinde auch dann
strom wenn der aus dem netz einmal
ausfällt
in der grundversorgung sind wie autonom
als würden wir sie hinter gesichert wir
können die feuerwehren die kindergarten
schule
wir können das seniorenheim das heizhaus
bekennen dass alles selbst mit strom
betrieben sichere stromversorgung beim
blackout in der steiermark ist das
möglich ein großflächiger stromausfall
dagegen ist deutschland nicht gewappnet
weder heute noch vor 15 jahren
also die nacht war sehr kurz und das ist
so ein klassischer moment gewesen
moniert morgens wach und ist es sofort
der erste gedanke der stromausfall das
ausmaß war ja quasi erst am teil des
nachts aber für alle beteiligten erst
eigentlich am nächsten morgen spürbar
ist auf der einen seite eine winterliche
märchenlandschaft draußen es war auf der
anderen seite aber auch gespenstisch
also es waren ja keine leuchtreklamen
eingeschaltet die geschäfte hatten
weitgehend zu
der damalige wehrführer musste erstmal
priorisieren wer hat eigentlich jetzt
welche priorität denn es war relativ
klar nachdem die leitungen
zusammengebrochen waren
das wird mehrere tage und stunden dauern
bis das repariert werden konnte man war
ein gewisser weise gar nicht darauf
vorbereitet viele nicht das merkt man
daran dass viele plötzlich sagt ja das
hatten wir gar nicht gedacht dass das
alles so zusammen hängt wenn der strom
weg ist was dann also plötzlich wechselt
die ganze kommunikation fällt weg die
ganze information fällt erstmal sind
viele leute schon direkt zur feuerwehr
gekommen und haben um hilfe gebeten weil
es ja nicht anrufen konnten viele
landwirte haben sich gemeldet weil sie
generatoren brauchten um in irgendeiner
form ihre welt maschinen zu betreiben
leute die pflegebedürftige personen zu
hause hatten nadine sauerstoff in den
aktions gerät hatten die kamen auch in
not weil die leute konnten den
sauerstoff nicht mehr adäquat versorgt
werden
da im grunde ist das ganze leben in der
stadt zusammengebrochen
berlin im februar 2009 10 gehen im
stadtteil köpenick am frühen nachmittag
die lichter aus ein bagger durch trends
zwei bauarbeiten zwei kabel die folge
etwa 80.000 menschen sind ohne strom
die infrastruktur daten zu verarbeiten
schnell über handys oder sonstwie etwas
an die menschen informationen zu bringen
fällt weg wir haben ausfälle dann die
die krankenhäuser können nach 34 tagen
weil der sprit aus ist für ihre notstrom
aggregate können sie auch nicht mehr
ihre funktionen aufrecht erhalten
auch in einer köpenicker klinik fällt
das notstromaggregat aus 23 patienten
müssen verlegt werden
nach 31 stunden endet der
katastrophenfall glimpflich es hätte
schlimmer kommen können für die
hauptstadt wir hatten ja hier in berlin
großes glück gehabt denn wenn wir uns
diesen kartenausschnitt betrachten der
in köpenick betroffen war dann war das
zwar ein verhältnismäßig großes gebiet
es wohl aber sehr wenig einwohner im
verhältnis zu ihr zum beispiel neukölln
oder so in diesem gebiet offen wenn man
jetzt von einem globalen stromausfall
für ganz berlin zum beispiel sprechen
würde
ist ja die frage ja wo finde ich denn
dann eigentlich noch geeignete
krankenhaus kapazitäten die sind dann
halt womöglich weiter weg der
stromausfall in köpenick der berliner
senat hat reagiert und mehr geld für den
katastrophenschutz bereit gestellt etwa
eine million euro pro jahr
erst jetzt nachdem ernstfall doch
katastrophenschützer häusler kann das
zögern der politik nachvollziehen
es geht immer um die abwägung zwischen
den ganz konkreten sachen die so vor der
haustür liegen also die frage zum
beispiel nämlich eine million euro in
die hand gebe ich die aus für den neubau
von einer kita oder investiere ich in
etwas abstraktes wie jetzt im
katastrophenschutz wo wenn man glück hat
es ist eine rein präventive maßnahme ist
und dann muss ich eben abwägen ok eine
million ganz konkret eine million
abstrakt und deswegen ist das sehr sehr
schwierig für die politik bund und
länder haben in den vergangenen jahren
mehr geld in den katastrophenschutz
gesteckt das bundesinnenministerium
stellt auf anfrage von frontal 21 fest
zitat grundsätzlich sind die akteure in
bund und ländern sowie die kritischen
infrastrukturen 2020 besser aufgestellt
als dies noch 2011 der fall war
gleichzeitig räumt das ministerium
schwachstellen ein insbesondere bei der
notstromversorgung von kritischer
infrastruktur
beispiel wasserwerke wie sollen die ohne
strom trinkwasser produzieren noch immer
mangelt es bei einem blackout an
widerstandsfähigkeit die politik spricht
von resilienz und die fehlt aus dem
bundesinnenministerium ein eingeständnis
hier gilt es die resilienz perspektive
bundesweit auf grundlage von
risikoanalysen zu erhöhen
[Musik]
das ist schon eine note wenn man im
stall steht und die kühe blöcken und man
kann nichts machen mit der hand melken
ist heute gar nicht mehr möglich die
tiere sie es nicht gewohnt und auch die
kraft in den armen hat man nicht mehr um
100 kühe zu melken beispielsweise oder
wenn es noch 50 sind das schaffen sie
nicht also keine kann keine chance und
ja dagegen die ersten kannst du dann
auch mit einem notstromaggregat bei uns
vielleicht mal aushelfen
in der nachmittags auch noch mit dem
einen riegel zu einem anderen betrieb
gefahren
da wurde dann abenteuerlichste anklemmen
gemacht also ich sag immer wieder es war
ein glück dass am wochenende wirklich
keiner war dabei draufgegangen ist
weiter lagen in strippen auf dem schnee
und los damit noch vielleicht die
maschine wieder ans laufen bekommen
wir haben dann macht sich kein bild
davon wie sehr ein landwirtschaftlicher
betrieb auf strom angewiesen ist
das fängt an bei melk maschinen also die
kühe haben wirklich auch gelitten
und das ist dann schon so ich glaube so
ein gefühl der ohnmacht und das ist kein
gutes gefühl
an der stelle und für jemanden der seine
tiere liebt sind ist das kann man das
nicht gut haben wenn sie wirklich da
stehen wir aber man hat keine handhabe
das war für die landwirte sehr bedrängen
also das war schon auch für branchen
existenzgefährdend wenn man plötzlich
die tiere ja nicht mehr versorgen kann
oder auch nicht mehr ihr leben retten
kann
[Musik]
haßfurt in unterfranken
die stadt hat schon früh auf die
stromerzeugung mit regenerativer energie
gesetzt schon heute kann hier der
strombedarf co2 neutral gedeckt werden
ein nützlicher nebeneffekt durch die
eigene stromversorgung ist die stadt
auch auf einem blackout vorbereitet wenn
wir jetzt unser unserer stadtwerke
anschauen
ein relativ kleiner stadtwerk produziert
mit hilfe von vier verschiedenen
regenerativen energiearten strom über
sonne über windkraft über
kraft-wärme-kopplung und auch über
biogas und wenn irgendwann mein blackout
ist dann brauche ich keine angst
wir werden vom stadtwerk haßfurt weiter
versorgt die wasserversorgung der stadt
ist heute schon sicher
selbst wenn der strom ausfällt das ist
nur möglich weil ausreichend energie vor
ort produziert wird mit windrädern
technisch komplett unabhängig vom
stromnetz das wort noch nicht für den
katastrophenfall will die stadt weiter
investieren in intelligente
steuerungssysteme für den selbst
erzeugten strom also für uns
regenerative energien sind einfach das
nonplusultra und letztendlich macht es
uns unabhängig von allem anderen wir
sind wir sind gewappnet für einen
blackout aber es kostet uns keinen cent
mehr
wir sind sogar teilweise wenn man wenn
man strompreise beispielsweise vergleich
günstiger als viele andere versorger
hier in deutschland
[Musik]
jetzt auf dem markt gestanden haben nach
drei tagen am sonntag
da war ja alles dunkel keine
schaufenster beleuchtung kein garnichts
als da plötzlich auf einmal die
schaufenster beleuchtung wieder
angegangen ist um mich herum das war ein
auch von normalität
die bundeswehr ist in der nacht von
samstag auf sonntag nach ochtrup gerufen
worden und hat
ich weiß gar nicht wie viele lkw
ladungen notstromaggregate mitgebracht
und dann tatsächlich die innenstadt am
sonntag wieder mit strom versorgen
können
da ist vielen schon deutlich geworden
wie fragile dieses system letztendlich
auch sein kann
die elektrizität ist ja das ist quasi
das dass das blut in den in den in der
heutigen gesellschaft was alles zum
zirkulieren bringt und wenn das nicht
mehr da ist und wir da quasi so ein
herzinfarkt erleiden
im fokus stehen bleibt dann aber ein
großes problem an der stelle was alle
festgestellt haben es ist ja regional
jetzt gewesen dass der stromausfall war
wenn das für die gesamte bundesrepublik
über längere zeit wird dann wird es
sicherlich ausmaße haben die wir noch
gar nicht abschätzen können